[Music]
most of us know what these emojis and
these numbers but what if everyone in
the world always used the same writing
system while still speaking completely
different languages it is actually not a
myth to say that writing unified the
Chinese culture there are many many
small groups of dialects in China but we
all use this one rating system which are
the characters that make things easier
for people you speaking different
language how do they understand each
other but written language which is
great
just like emojis and hieroglyphs in
ancient Egypt Chinese doesn't use an
alphabet based on sounds but symbols
denoting meaning so how does Chinese
work well each character represents a
word or a concept and you stack them
together like Lego bricks to build more
words some of them also look like what
they represent a mountain may look just
like a mountain with a peak in the
middle and Fire resembles some blazing
logs put them together and you get
volcano and lots of the writing is the
same between China and Japan - I know
this better some so like my dog are
really cute I guess Chinese is the most
concise written language in the world so
we'd use less paper and it looks
beautiful for centuries people have
tried to invent the perfect universal
written language and Chinese has
actually been considered before
universal language schemes were
particularly popular in the 17th century
what people would have assumed that the
origin of language theologically was in
the Garden of Eden so the whole world
would have spoken one language but then
with the Tower of Babel those languages
were broken into a multitude of
languages
they reckoned it would take a universal
language to get us all back to heaven
and Francis Bacon assumed that a
language like Chinese and its writing
system would have qualified because of
this special relationship between the
sign and what it symbolized but there's
a problem because Chinese characters
often represent whole words there are a
lot of them tons how many are there han
ping oh I'm sorry I don't know I don't
know it's for many two thousand eight
nine thousand a million not quite but it
is very hard to say when dictionary has
around sixty four thousand characters if
you know five thousand characters you're
doing very well and well some of them
kind of look like what they represent
most of them don't really in fact some
of them are incredibly complicated
this one has 57 strokes it's actually
the name of a kind of noodle yep in fact
Chinese is so complicated that since the
1950s a simplified system of characters
has been used in mainland China along
with a romanized alphabet called pinyin
so Chinese characters might not become a
universal writing system any time soon
the trouble is not just inventing one
but getting people to use it and it
wouldn't be easy for the whole world to
agree on the same set of meaning
language you need a cultural context you
cannot really just borrow or create and
maybe it's actually are different
languages that make us special every
year we lose hundreds of languages from
from this planet and I would fear that a
universal language might lead to
cultural impoverishment so now perhaps
we should just stick to emojis I use
very simple like and dislike and then
I designed my own sometimes how do
people know what they are then David
they have to guess
[Music]
you